so if I have a 20-year vision
Tied by another 20 years after that and
I'm willing to play offense aggressively
right now this is not a time to play
defense this is a time to play offense
and you can't play offense if you've
made the right choices the last five
years 10 years if the last five years
you were planning on becoming a Deca
millionaire because Bitcoin was going to
go to a quarter million dollars well
then you took a hit if you were planning
on becoming a millionaire because you
thought a a handful of nfts you thought
the land you were going to sell for 5.2
million and you bought it for 10 grand
well then you took a risk because the
get rich quick type of models man that
takes a lot of people out but you know
if your philosophy is a real philosophy
Builds on data growth real substance
versus just pure luck I'm hoping to get
rich